l'assassinât de béchir gemayel il
inquiétudes dans tout le proche-orient
et dans les capitales occidentales
l'armée israélienne pénètre dans
beyrouth ouest
yasser arafat a bien rencontré le pape
au vatican en privé les deux hommes ont
parlé du problème de jérusalem du sommet
13 et de la situation des chrétiens au
liban la france d'emprunter 28 milliards
de francs à l'étranger pour défendre sa
monnaie
hausse des prix au mois d'août +0 3%
la mort de la princesse grace de monaco
sa plus jeune fille n'a pas encore été
informé ses fans y est atteinte aux
vertèbres cervicales
enfin les coupes d'europe de football
des fêtes à l'étranger de paris saint
germain et de bordeaux mais messieurs
bonsoir de toute cette actualité très
pesant de vous l'avez constaté avec nos
titres c'est la mort du président de la
république libanaise qui semble la plus
lourde de conséquences c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les phalanges
chrétiennes dont l'immeuble venait
d'exploser hier en fin d'après midi ont
attendu minuit pour annoncer la nouvelle
au monde un monde
consternés et désorienté tout est à
refaire dit on un peu partout dans les
capitales qui compte mais avant tout
commentaire
les faits avec morizet repère quelques
minutes après l'attentât c'était la
panique dans les rues de beyrouth
l'émotion était d'autant plus grande que
l'on commençait à se réhabituer à la
paix revenue depuis presque un mois
après le départ des combattants
mais d'abord s'il en a su tout de suite
que l' affaire était grave
trois étages de l'immeuble défaillances
ont été fondés il est certainement
beaucoup de victimes
d'abord on a cru dur comme fer aux
miracles
béchir gemayel qui étaient dans
l'immeuble avec ses amis l'échec
phalangistes avait échappé à la mort
certains étaient même sûr qu'on l'avait
vu monter dans une ambulance simplement
avec une blessure légère à la jambe
cela entre 4 heures et 5 heures de
l'après-midi vers 7 heures et demie du
soir au publie un premier bilan partiel
bien entendu huit morts 40 blessés
malgré tout les partisans de gemayel
manifestent leur joie dans les rues ils
croient leur chef sains et saufs
et puis à partir de 11 heures du soir
signe inquiétant les radios libanaise ne
diffuse plus que de la musique classique
à minuit le chef du gouvernement
monsieur wajam annonce que béchir
gemayel est mort en tout il y à 20 morts
et 60 blessés
un deuil de sept jours a donc été
proclamée au liban toute la montagne
chrétienne déjà pris ce deuil et dès cet
après midi le président de la république
a été enterré dans le vide le village
des gemayel big three ya le ministre
israélien de la défense ariel sharon est
venu présenter ses condoléances à la
famille
nous ne l'avions pas invité a fait
savoir un milicien phalangistes c'est
que dans le même temps les forces
israéliennes pénétraient dans beyrouth
ouest gérard ce bac
quelques combats dont on ne connaît pas
encore l'importance ont marqué la
progression des forces israéliennes dans
le secteur ouest de beyrouth
cette avance est fait sur les axes
classique de pénétration à partir du
port sur le front de mer jusqu'à l'hôtel
normandie dans le secteur sud à partir
12 aille vers le complexe touristique
somme erlang dans le secteur central de
la route de l'aéroport vers les camps de
réfugiés palestiniens au point de
passage du musée des chars
cava comme celui ci ont pris position
coupant la circulation entre les deux
secteurs de la ville officiellement
jérusalem le porte parole de l'armée a
déclaré que ces mouvements de troupes
étaient destinées à empêcher des
développements graves et à maintenir le
calme
monsieur chafik al wazzan le premier
ministre libanais a rejeté les
explications israélienne pour les
libanais qui lie à seulement 24 heures
espérer que le calme allait enfin
définitivement s'installer à beyrouth
s'est de nouveau la panique et la fuite
des immeubles touchés par les combats
l'aviation israélienne a survolé à
plusieurs reprises la ville ce matin des
vols de reconnaissance sans
bombardements alors que selon la radio
des forces progressistes des avions de
transport s'était posé sur l'aéroport
international de beyrouth pour y
débarquer des troupes israéliennes
menahem begin dans un message de
condoléances s'est déclaré choqué par la
disparition du grand patriote qui était
béchir gemayel et il est vrai que cette
disparition va considérablement gêné et
embarrasser israël idier baume didier
pour istres pour y serait le plus urgent
c'est d'empêcher une guerre civile où il
ne pourrait plus trouver ses cibles il
faudra ensuite repartir de zéro c'est à
dire permettre l'installation d'un
gouvernement solide à beyrouth
à jérusalem on minimise ce soir
l'ampleur du déploiement des troupes
israéliennes à beyrouth ouest
il s'agit dit on de mouvements limités
destiné à empêcher la détérioration de
la situation en faisant tampon entre les
milices libanaises rival sans préciser
jusqu'où on ira
c'est ainsi pense-t-on à jérusalem que
l'on parviendra à rétablir l'ordre
la classe politique libanaise pour alors
se reprendre et réamorcer le processus
constitutionnel entendre les
responsables israéliens la tendance est
plutôt à la tente ou à la résignation
on craint que le coût de béchir gemayel
ne se reproduise pas les dirigeants
déclarent qu'ils ont intérêt un
gouvernement fort à beyrouth fort est
prêt à signer un traité de paix il
s'empresse d'ajouter qu'ils n'ont pas le
pouvoir ni la volonté de pousser un
nouveau chef d'état l'incertitude des
israéliens ce soir rappelle un peu celle
qui a prévalu après la mort de sadate
avec un contexte inverse
israël a toutes les cartes militaires en
main et c'est le politique qui lui file
à travers les
didier est ce que ça veut dire que la
présence israélienne au liban va durer
plus longtemps que prévu
la présence israélienne au liban menahem
begin a dit qu'elle pourrait se terminer
au bout de quelques semaines c'est la
première fois que l'on parle en termes
de semaine en israël
il l'a déclaré après avoir rencontré
l'émissaire américain maurice très peur
néanmoins l'armée le chef de l'état
major raphaël eytan précise toujours que
sa halle s'apprête et se prépare à
passer l'hiver au liban oui cela dit le
chef de l'opposition israélienne shimon
peres a pour sa part mis en garde le
gouvernement béguines donc contre toute
intervention dans les affaires
intérieures libanaises ne serait-ce est
il dit que par des voies détournées
certains rapports sauf pour le banc pour
la paix pour la stabilité dans les
banques même bachir gemayel d'un jeune
homme qui donnait beaucoup d'espoir qui
est elie par les parlements et pour le
moment n'existait pas
un autre candidat pour devenir les
présidents sur les situations à beyrouth
à mon avis les miennes et solutions
cette fausse multinationales qui va
garder les situations un beyrouth même
malgré la guerre malgré les tensions je
pense que tous les partis sont fatigués
avec la guerre même avec les
distractions et en force multinationale
qui va arriver immédiatement à beyrouth
paie vraiment contribué pour arriver
encore une fois la stabilité pour les
bains donner une chance qui les
capitales arabes système capital à 100
ans quand on travaille on est proche
oui il n'y a guère que les viandes mien
et les syriens pour se réjouir à mots
couverts de la disparition de béchir
gemayel partout ailleurs l'inquiétude
très vive la plupart des états arabes
modérés comme l'arabie saoudite avait
finalement accepté la présence de béchir
gemayel à la tête de l'état libanais
quant aux occidentaux ils savent bien
que le proche orient risque fort d'être
à nouveau embrasé à londres à paris à
washington la même condamnation est tout
à l'heure les etats unis ont appelé
israël à ne rien faire qui puisse
accroître la tension au liban
edwards est une rapidité à laquelle on
n'est pas habitués ici à washington la
maison blanche bien très
diplomatiquement de demander à israël de
ne rien faire qui puisse accroître la
tension au liban
sous-entendu ne pas profiter de
l'attentât d'hier soir pour s'engager
dans des opérations qui pourraient
remettre en cause les points acquis par
la diplomatie américaine ces dernières
semaines parallèlement au département
d'état en a reçus ce matin des
assurances de la part des responsables
israéliens qui affirme que lors des
opérations militaires ne sont que des
mesures de précaution un argument qui
n'a sans doute pas vraiment convaincu
les américains
d'où ce nouvel avertissement de la
maison blanche à israël et il faut bien
remarquer que ce matin les américains ne
se sont pas contentés de faire appel au
parc
en présence comme ils le font d'habitude
mais se sont adressés directement et
nommément au gouvernement israélien
oui d'autant qu'à l'instant on m'apprend
que les forces israéliennes viennent de
pénétrer dans le camps palestiniens de
sabra qui se trouve dans la banlieue sud
de beyrouth à paris à l'issue du conseil
des ministres le gouvernement a
réaffirmé la nécessité de l'évacuation
de toutes les forces étrangères du liban
et la nécessité de l'ordre dans ce pays
alors maintenant semblent retraçant la
brève carrière de béchir gemayel en qui
certains n'avaient vu qu'un chef de clan
lors de sa désignation comme président
la république mais qui très vite et est
en train de s'imposer par sa
personnalité
bruno alves 10 ans s'est vu des lignes
c'est la pierre c'est la vie c'est la
paix pour tous les libanais vous n'avez
pas peur que de l'autre côté
rien
accepter la présidence de la république
en ce qui concerne gdf
l'homme qui s'exprime ainsi n'est autre
que pierre gemayel le père du président
élu fondateur des phalanges chrétiennes
le fedayin de combattants son fils
milite dans les organisations armées
depuis l'adolescente ici en 76 il n'a
pas encore 29 ans mais comment déjà les
milices qui combattent la présence
palestinienne au liban
avocat de profession il a vite abandonné
le barreau et s'est rapidement révélée
comme le partisan acharné de l'ordre et
de la fermeté ses adversaires sont
éliminés impitoyablement et lorsque
s'ouvre en juillet dernier la campagne
présidentielle il se présente
israël a envahi le sud liban la bataille
de beyrouth fait rage mais le 23 août
les députés votent élise le chef des
forces libanaises à la tête du pays
à l'heure du scrutin les parlementaires
musulmans se sont ralliés à sa
candidature mais le président élu s'est
pourtant qu'il devra encore convaincre
qu'il est le président de tous les
libanais limité et très difficile à fès
comme chez vous comme chez nous comme
pato ailleurs dans le monde démocratique
il y aura un pouvoir et un gouvernement
et il y aura une opposition donc celui
qui veut faire de l'opposition de face
et celui qui voudra participer à
l'élaboration de ce programme à son
exécution pour confond le problème de
votre pays le président sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de milice et militaires ne vous
inquiétez pas pour ce problème tout ces
milices selon dissoudre toutes ses
ministres dont ce traité il y aura une
armée nationale et un pouvoir central
fort nous avons plusieurs armées
étrangères qui sont sur notre sol il
faudra voir comment traiter tous ces
problèmes et voir quel est le prix à
payer pour tous hérité que ce soit si
bien israéliens que palestiniens
actuellement se le dire mais
certainement nous aurons d'autres
problèmes à affronter
on est à fond ça avec tout le courage et
toute la lucidité nécessaire le peuple
libanais via donc de subir en l'espace
de quelques mois à peine 2 choc profond
d'abord bien sûr l'invasion israélienne
sur son sol et hier l'assassinât de son
nouveau président tout le problème
maintenant est de savoir si ce dernier
traumatisme provoquera un sursaut
d'unité nationale ou au contraire
entraînera à nouveau le chaos et la
guerre cifq incontestablement béchir
gemayel gêner beaucoup moins
aussi bien à l'intérieur du liban qu'à
l'extérieur de par d'abord cette
personnalité son passé disons de chef de
clan mais aussi le gêner car depuis son
élection le dépendance politique souvent
opposé s'était rallié à lui toutefois
depuis pour beaucoup également
il incarnait l'espoir d'un début de
solution même si certains au liban était
sceptique sur les méthodes employées
dans un pays qui compte douze
communautés politiques et religieux
rival toutes les hypothèses sur les
origines de la tentation permise
cependant par sa minutie et sa
sophistication cet attentat ne peut-être
que l'oeuvre de professionnels
parfaitement entraîne aujourd'hui le
liban connaît encore un vide politique
et psychologique
béchir gemayel c'est vrai était
contestée mais on voit mal aujourd'hui
quelles personnalités ayant disons le
même charisme pourrait lui succéder
même si certains avancent déjà le nom de
son frère aîné amine gemayel
comment après tous ces drames les
libanais ne croirai t-il pas la fatalité
car une nouvelle fois tout est à refaire
au liban ou plutôt tout est à refaire au
proche orient
oui nous ne reviendrons pas tout sur les
multiples télégramme qui se sont
entassés sur le bureau du présent sarkis
qu'ils ne continuent qui continuent pour
l'instant d'assumer sa charge vous
rappelle que son successeur n'a été que
désigner et non pas officiellement
investie selon certains une nouvelle
élection pourrait avoir lieu dès la
semaine prochaine
pour ibrahim sousse le porte-parole de
l'ol paie en france il sera elle est le
principal bénéficiaire de cet attentat
qui lui permet de poursuivre sa
stratégie
yasser arafat a de son côté rejeté toute
responsabilité dans cette attaque sinaï
yasser arafat qui est aujourd'hui rome
avec un point fort violemment contesté
en israël comme dans les milieux juifs
internationaux une rencontre tête à tête
avec le pain jean paul ii au vatican
c'est donc bien une audience privée que
le pape jean paul ii a finalement
accordé à yasser arafat
il est vrai que ce tête à tête ne s'est
pas déroulé dans les appartements
et du pape comme c'est le cas
généralement pour les chefs d'état ou
les personnalités officielles mais dans
une pièce de l'un des palais du vatican
il faut noter que jean paul ii a donc
pris certaines précautions de pure forme
il est vrai mais des précautions tout de
même c'est important car il s'agit de
savoir quel degré quelle dose de
reconnaissance sinon officielle du mas
politique le chef de l'église catholique
peut accorder au président de l'ol paie
et c'est extrêmement important pour l'ol
paie cette attestation de légitimité de
la part du chef 2 million et 2 millions
de catholiques avant de recevoir yasser
arafat jean paul ii a énergiquement
condamné l'attentât contre le président
gemayel
il a dit je condamne cet acte insensé de
violences qui s'ajoutent à tant d'autres
yasser arafat qui est donc arrivé ce
matin à rome a dit lui que la mort du
président gemayel et la poursuite d'un
plan israélien contre deux peuples
les peuples palestinien et libanais
c'est un prétexte pour continuer
l'occupation israélienne du liban a
précisé yasser arafat
en fait le président de l'ol paie a bel
et bien été reçu comme un chef d'état en
italie il a déjeuné en tête à tête avec
le président de la république sandro
pertini acclamé à la conférence de
l'union interparlementaire yasser arafat
a dit que les palestiniens étaient prêts
à faire preuve de modération
si l'occident faisait un geste concret
pour la solution de leurs problèmes mais
il a demandé aussi que l'union
interparlementaire constitue une
commission d' enquête sur les crimes de
guerre d'israël au liban où soixante dix
mille personnes ont été tuées ou
blessées
yasser arafat qui fait non armés pour
paris l'opap ce qui paraît normal mais
que les palestiniens présente comme un
fait exceptionnel une actualité très
riche également en france actualité
essentiellement économiques avec d'abord
ce deuxième bon indice des prix 0 3%
pour le mois d'août 0 3% comme au mois
de juillet voilà qui fait ramener le
glissement des prix un rythme annuel de
9 4% et qui traduit incontestablement
une décélération de l'inflation pour
parler comme les économistes c'est la
preuve que les français comprennent
l'enjeu de la désinflation vient de
faire savoir jacques delors qui se
réjouit bien entendu de cet indice
exceptionnel at il dit dans le même
temps le gouvernement lançait un emprunt
de 4 milliards de dollars 28 milliards
de francs sur le marché international un
emprunt destiné à reconstituer les
réserves de devises de la banque de
france quelque peu malmené ces derniers
jours est donc destiné également à
défendre le franc est là le présent d'un
public a été très net
écoutez jacques attali qui horreur
reprenait ses propos à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
un de répliquer à toute nouvelle attaque
des opérateurs internationaux
il convient de mettre en oeuvre les
mesures de fermeté supplémentaires
utiles à la conduite de notre action sur
la plupart des plans on constate grâce à
l'effort du plus grand nombre des
français
des progrès réels et constant telle
neige
copé de production
dès lors
de mobiliser les crocs
je pense que malgré ce léger sifflement
vous avez compris l'essentiel de cette
déclaration très ferme du chef de l'état
alors premiers résultats à l'issue de
l'annnonce de cet emprunt un
raffermissement de la monnaie française
sur les marchés de londres et de paris
et un cours de 7 francs 0,6 pour le
dollar contre cette france la veille
voilà donc une nouvelle priorité pour le
gouvernement on la croyait philippe
sassi a réservé au gouvernement
précédent celui de raymond barre
peut-être mais en tout cas on peut
constater que le tandem mauroy de l'or
vient de recevoir un appui éclatant
celui du président de la république
aucune autre intervention ne pouvait
davantage conforter une politique de
rigueur économique qui a pour piller
centrale la défense du franc l'emprunt a
donc deux grands objectifs d'abord nous
procurer d'une munition pour défendre
notre monnaie et ceci en doublant
pratiquement nous réservons dollars et
ensuite proclamé solennellement la
résolution du gouvernement il faut dire
que le foin est attaqué depuis 15 jours
parce que à l'étranger ont douté de la
volonté du gouvernement de se mobiliser
pour défendre la monnaie aujourd'hui le
doute n'est plus permis il faut rappeler
qu'au début du 1974 le gouvernement
français avait débat avait déjà lancé un
emprunt similaire de 1 milliard et demi
de dollars qu'ils n'avaient pas utilisé
oui ça peut reconnaître que l'économie
française avec difficulté est ce que ça
vaut pas suffisant pour casser la
spéculation quand tout cas dans les
premiers jours des vul et les baisses
actuellement lé recul du dollar et d'une
marque peut-être il faut dire que le
gouvernement bénéficie d'un répit de
plusieurs mois pendant lequel s'il veut
retrouver la confiance de l'étranger lui
faut réussir sur trois points d'abord
diminuer l'inflation ensuite résorber
les grands déficits et notamment celui
de la santé et enfin commencer à
redresser le commerce extérieur faute de
résultats probants dans ces trois
domaines
les observateurs étrangers disait
aujourd'hui que le franc pourrait bien
se retrouver de nouveau attaqué au début
de l'année prochaine pour l'inflation
est en bonne voie puisque
c'est un deal de 0 3% constitue une
bonne surprise il ya huit mois
c'est d'une effectivement une très bonne
surprise il faut dire qu évidemment la
fermeture de nombreux magasins au mois
d'août empêche de faire tous les relevés
de prix habituel et donc que cet indice
n'est pas parfaitement complet en mai
enfin il confirme quand même la très
grande satisfaction que l'on peut avoir
ou bleu qhd et c'est incontestablement
une très bonne nouvelle pour jacques
delors au moment où le président lui
accorde son appui
enfin patrick il faut bien remarquer
qu'après le terrorisme c'est le franck
allemagne le président de la république
à monter en première ligne
la dernière information économique
d'importance ce soir l'exonération
totale des actifs professionnels de
l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes c'était
une promesse du chef de l'état il ya
tout juste un an
désormais donc les investissements
réalisés pendant les trois années à
venir serviront en quelque sorte d'
avance au paiement de l'impôt sur la
fortune que devrait payer ses chefs
d'entreprise durant ces trois années
c'est un petit peu compliqué un peu
compliqué a résumé mais les principaux
intéressés savent ce qu'il en est le
cnpf s'est d'ailleurs réjoui cette
mesure un grand pas en avant a dit tout
à l'heure son président yvon gattaz qui
juge toutefois les dispositions
insuffisante
on ne peut pas parler en effet at-il dit
beat generation totale de l'outil de
travail
mais ces mesures conclut quand même le
cnpf devrait donner un peu plus
confiance dans les chances de l'économie
française quatrième gros titres de
l'actualité ce soir la mort de la
princesse grace de monaco on l'a appris
à peu près à la même heure que celle du
président gemayel vers minuit et sans
avoir les mêmes conséquences politiques
bien sûr c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous n'en parlons que maintenant elle a
jeté une immense consternation un peu
partout tout le monde l'aimait cette
princesse qui avait tout réussi mais qui
faisait croire aux contes de noël et
s'est bien vendu en principauté que
l'abattement était le plus sensible
aujourd'hui danielle cattelin quand je
me suis réveillé ce matin à l'hôtel
quelqu'un m'a dit que grèce qu'elle y
était mort qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est terrible
toutes les boutiques ont fermé comme ça
c'est d'un commun accord bien ses
comptes annuels
c'était vraiment exceptionnel qu'est ce
qu'elle avait fait pour la principauté
lui avait redonné le visage grave devant
le palais les gars pour nous un brassard
de deuil il s'implique
que chaque green
pourquoi vous avez l'impression d'avoir
perdu une année d'autant plus que ma
famille a toujours été à côté de la
famille princière mon père c'est un gars
de chambre 3il d'albert 1er on avait une
grande estime pour elle et puis elle a
fait beaucoup de choses
vraiment elle pensait que
car le bio ce que je me sens bien je
suis venu pour une roma ça la rend
hommage à la princesse grace que nous
aimons beaucoup
pourquoi le niveau est bas pas c'est une
personne qui était premièrement qui
avait de la classe
elle est très très très sympathique et
surtout elle s'occupait beaucoup des
déshérités
on a l'impression ici que les
monégasques ont perdu une amie et une
protectrice ou c'est moi je suis
républicaine alors mes a à monaco je
suis pour la principauté pour la famille
pendant tout l'après-midi pour moins
trois jours radio monte-carlo diffusera
de la musique classique interrompue
seulement par des bulletins
d'information depuis 16h cet après midi
les mailles des gars savent qu'ils
peuvent se recueillir devant la
dépouille de la princesse grace exposé
dans la chapelle palatine du palais
princier
le palais a également annoncé qu'ils ne
recevraient que des fleurs
les drapeaux seront donc mis en berne
pour lui jours à monaco les obsèques
auront lieu samedi à 11 heures la
princesse sera inhumé à l'intérieur de
la cathédrale d'ici la blanquette aura
sans doute avancé car il reste de
nombreux points à éclaircir dans les
circonstances de l'accident
isabel peichert la route qui descend du
montage est là la principauté de monaco
est très dangereuse et c'est précisément
là que la princesse grace et sa fille
stéphanie ont raté un virage en épingle
à cheveux lundi matin alors qu'elle
regagnait le château des grimaldi
quelques minutes avant l'accident un
gendarme de la turbie affirmé avoir vu
passer la princesse grâce au volant de
sa rover mais la voiture est partie tout
droit cinq tonneaux 32 mètres de chute
contusions et vertèbre déplacée pour
stéphanie fracture très sérieuse pour
grace de monaco
mais la voiture n'est plus sur les lieux
l'automobile club monégasque que la
tracter jusqu'à l'intérieur du palais
princier et le parquet de nice n'a pas
encore demandé des expertises perte de
contrôle du véhicule défaillance du
système de freins le témoignage de
stéphanie serait capital pour le juge
niçois mais pourra-t-il interroger la
princesse monaco est un état souverain
oui la princesse stéphanie qui était
avec sa mère dans la voiture accidentée
souffre finalement de lésions aux
vertèbres cervicales ont dit qu'elles
n'auraient pas encore été informés de
amor de graisse de monaco grace de
monaco qui laissera derrière elle une
traînée des toiles de petites étoiles
dans la tête de la plupart d'entre nous
france roche
qu'elle était belle grèce kelly à 27 ans
le jour où dans la cathédrale de monaco
elle devint princesse grimaldi elle
abandonnait le cinéma mais les caméras
allait continuer à la suivre à épier ses
sourires ses émotions ses silences
à travers 25 ans d'une vie d'altesse
élégant sans raideur dignité sans auteur
sérénité sans effort elle présidait un
gala de charité rebaptisé un théâtre
lancer un festival d'art ou décernait un
prix suivi souvent de ces enfants qui
avait hérité soit sa beauté soit sa
classe soit sa malice son unique rôle
était devenu soutenir aider défendre
sauver venise par exemple menacée par
les eaux et venise c'est un défi à
l'ingéniosité de l'homme fidh est ce
qu'elle est je crois maintenant les
experts en trouver des solutions alors
assez indifférent en sept ans de
carrière et dix films elle avait révélé
un coeur de feu sous les passionnés
touchante mais forte elle savait jouer
le désir ou le désespoir sont clean de
ses boucles ne bouge sans cesser d'être
une dame est lui les plus brillants
partenaires gary cooper cary grant clark
gable frank sinatra james stewart
il gagna un oscar d'interprétation pour
un rôle pourtant peu fait pour elle une
fille dans la campagne
la princesse est morte mais grèce vit
encore laiteuse et d'auray sur un écran
de paris dans le crime était presque
parfait
m
cette femme dès demain soir
mago mairie wendy et aussi aux nôtres
j'étais
et puisque la victime des drames
policiers gardant degré cette image de
la belle élégante de haute société
chantant l'amour avec tant de pudeur
dans l'abandon
oui non
q
jeudi
oh
voilà pour cette bien triste disparition
non loin de là à toulon une messe très
émouvante à la mémoire des 23 victimes
françaises de l'accident d'hélicoptère
de mannheim
au cours de la cérémonie plusieurs
parents des victimes qui revenait des
lieux d'accidents ont dû recevoir des
soins dans la cour de l'église
il faut encore savoir avant de passer
aux sports que oreste scalzone et c'est
à dire l'universitaire italiens arrêtés
il ya quinze jours à paris en vertu d'un
mandat d'arrêt international délivré par
l'italie a été remis en liberté mais il
devra toujours satisfaire au contrôle
judiciaire qu'il empêche par exemple de
quitter la capitale savoir aussi que à
la suite de la décision du premier
ministre de reporter à une date
ultérieure l'examen en conseil des
ministres du projet du 9e plan et bien
pierre mauroy cherche un petit peu à
minimiser l'aspect politique de la chose
ne s'agit absolument pas d'un aspect
d'un geste politique
c'était au savoir au cabinet de pierre
mauroy en soulignant que le texte
devrait faire l'objet d'une nouvelle
mouture plus peaufinée nombreux sont les
opératoire les observateurs avoir pensé
qu'il s'agissait d'une divergence entre
michel rocard et le premier ministre
savoir enfin que les usines d'aulnay
sous bois a de nouveau été paralysée cet
après midi par des arrêts de travail
chez citroën donc décidé par la maîtrise
et l'encadrement qui protestent contre
la présence de l'ouvrier marocain accusé
d'avoir agressé un contrôle et sport
donc avec les premières qualifications
pour les coupes d'europe de football
trois matches dans quelques secondes
ceux de saint-etienne de monaco de
sochaux et de monaco un petit peu plus
tard mais bordeaux et paris saint
germain ont déjà joué et déjà perdu cela
se passe ça se passait à l'extérieur et
leur situation ne semble quand même pas
catastrophique dominique le glou
après son récent succès sur laval en
championnat bordeaux seront d'être en
allemagne de l'est avec un moral
retrouvé un moral à la hauteur de ses
ambitions européennes mais en moins de
dix minutes carl zeiss iena ou son
savoir-faire bureau adresse une
transversale sur la gauche une remise en
retrait de cubjac et un premier but
qui est ce nous passe le libero de
l'équipe ça commence mal pour les
girondins pourtant giresse omniprésente
donnent le tournis à la solide défense
allemand sur place ils effacent by un
tir roissy en direction de la lucarne de
grappes en taille et la sq portier
allemand possède une détente
exceptionnelle deuxième mi temps un
corner joué à la rémoise pas rihanna une
balle qui traîne devant le but bordelais
erreurs à ne pas commettre devant
l'efficace ce n'est pas assez 2-0 pour
carl zeiss iéna on pense alors que cette
fois bordeaux ne s'en remettra pas c'est
mal connaître la volonté de son
capitaine giresse il exploite une
ouverture de tigana avec une petite
balle en cloche regard des biens est
idéal compte tenu de la taille du
gardien bordeaux revient à 2 buts à 1
juste le temps de reprendre espoir et
c'est la catastrophe en troisième but
suite à une mésentente ruffy espeche
d'obtenir le treizième homme qui vient à
peine de rentrer ne revient pas il
s'étonne mais pas pour longtemps et
aggravent la main fois un courriel un
bordeaux très malheureux ratera même un
penalty à la dernière minute par dieter
müller
vous ne verrez pas par contre regarder
ce tir de lacombe il aurait mérité un
meilleur sort
bordeaux garde une petite chance 15e
minute stoev tire le corner milanov
saute plus haut que tout mais enfin à 0
pour le premier match européen du paris
saint-germain difficile ramper en
matière mais sur ce boulet de canon de
la tête
il n'y avait pas grand chose à faire
mais curieusement les bulgares ne vont
pas cherché à emballer le match peu
d'occasions si ce n'est ici en seconde
période sous l'impulsion de valises
cosme et baratelli saut sur sa ligne
et ce sont les parisiens qui vont
s'enhardir en fin de match 86e minute
avant bâtir donné un gros push mais
hardy laisse ne peut profiter de
l'occasion et à la dernière minute de
jeu la plus belle occasion pour les
parisiens ardila s'envole sur la gauche
il cherche un partenaire démarqué
il trouve toko mais un défenseur bulgare
sauve sur sa ligne au ralenti le ballon
ne semble pas avoir franchi la ligne du
gardien bulgare en tout cas bonne
opération pour le paris saint germain
qui devra marquer deux buts au parc des
princes dans 15 jours pour se qualifier
voilà très rapidement maintenant les
pronostics pour le quarté de demain qui
se jouera à maisons laffitte dans le
handicap de la tamise le 3 le 2 le 7 le
18 le cese pardon le 13 le neuf le 8 et
le 17 secondes jeune femme nous faire
des propositions pour ce soir des
propositions de pronostic
ou en tout cas très vision pour la météo
et lisbeth et oui les propositions pas
du tout mal honnête je tiens à le
préciser est bien le bouton continue les
tc
et bien bien installé demain donc il va
continuer à faire très beau et très
chaud partout alors un peu de brume le
matin mais elle disparaîtra très vite
surtout dans la moitié nord de la france
ensuite donc un beau soleil partout avec
tout de même des nuages mais seulement
l'après midi et même en soirée sur le
sud ouest et jusqu'au sud de la bretagne
avec une tendance orageuse des nuages
aussi sur le sud des alpes la côte
d'azur et la corse avec des risques
d'orages isolés mais ça bien sûr
seulement dans la soirée donc c'est du
beau temps partout côté température et
bien après la météo nationale les
températures vont rester tout à fait
estivale donc chaude pour cette période
de l'année avec 22 24 degrés en
normandie en bretagne mais partout
ailleurs des températures s'échelonnant
de 27 degrés à 30 degrés dans la moitié
sud donc ce sera vraiment chaud et même
lourd dans certains endroits surtout
donc sur le sud-ouest la côte d'azur et
la corse
voilà ce que nous réserve ce jeudi 16
septembre avec un soleil qui se fait de
plus en plus flâneur le matin puisqu'il
ne se lèvera qu à 7h29 pour se coucher à
20h01 soyons précis et ce sera la fête
des dix dit voilà il ya 23h15 jacques
mannino développera les titres que nous
avons rappelé pendant tout ce journal
l'assassinât de bachir gemayel lise
inquiétudes dans tout le proche orient
et en occident l'armée israélienne
pénètre dans beyrouth ouest
yasser arafat a bien rencontré le pape
au vatican privé les deux hommes ont
parlé du problème de jérusalem notamment
et de la situation des chrétiens au
liban
la france va emprunter 28 milliards de
francs à l'étranger pour défendre sa
monnaie
par ailleurs les prix au mois d'août
n'ont augmenté que de 0 3%
enfin je vous le rappelle la mort de la
princesse grace de monaco
voilà donc pour la fin de ce journal un
tout petit peu plus longue qu'à
l'habitude à demain 20h bonne soirée à
tous